[Music]
hey everyone I'm Jimmy hon this is my homie rookie
we're at the NHL Global Series in Melbourne rookie
what's up having a day having an absolute day this
is the first time here first time really going to
a live game of NHL can't wait to see what it holds
let's hit it they're going us let's go we got the
VIP treatment today rookie they feeling extremely
important hold up what's up how you doing why is
the stage set or what oh this is great the stage
is set Tom's never watched hockey before oh you
never oh no oh it's something that's very fresh to
me yeah he's going to be like what's this what's
this what's this genuinely a big crowd here of
course it's going to be a big crowd first time
in H's ever come to Melbourne we got these real
average seats right on the glass to smell them
then have a go at it look at it not bad at all
have a go at it have a go at this couple's pack
wow I don't even know what else to say this is
he it's hard work at the top mate I got to get
this on film this is too good propice spoil from
Melbourne Australia and Rod labor Arena the NHL
Global series presents the Arizona Coyotes and
the Los Angeles Kings who are the smaller ones
in the blue jerseys like local Little League
or something the first time in NHL history a
game has been played not only in Australia but in
the southern hemisphere man it's absolutely chalk
as in theia it's pack to the RS it's full sell is
[Applause] it it doesn't feel like I'm at mod lab
like a tennis center unless you watch us hockey
live you don't actually know how amazing it is
it's three periods how long 20 minutes how many
in a squad 20 on the bench at each time all boys
stay tight it oh the goal is a weapon obviously
they're well paded but no thanks so old mate
scared it before and he slapped it down with
his hand but that's chilling yeah you can tap
it with your hand uh you can essentially use any
part of your body to stop the park that's what I
see what's happen in is it an offside call or is
it it's when you send a park from the other side
of the Red Line pass the other Red Line right
so is it a disadvantage or an advantage to you
it's a disadvantage to if you paus it all right
okay how often are they changing lineup all the
time and that's the thing about ice it's like a
rolling interchange bench no wonder they got 20
blocks on the bench I'm knacked just watching
them what they can change in the middle of the
play yeah they do that you ever I at it before
I have it's exhausting they got to do that and
play hockey and not get smoked by this massive
block that's coming have him [Applause] yes have
him get him keep that man a [Applause]
contract yeah do man give them what they
want to see 5 minutes you get five weeks in the
AFL for that what's the [__] made vulcanized
rubber I guess reaction time's got to be out of
control don't you did what do you think how you
feeling super into it it's so good it needs to
happen more here come on we want to see it oh
it's and he scores in off prob from behind
the goal line off the back of the goalie's
legs as well so good P Kell is that good and KY
coming com out H now from vaki now melli a drive
and he scores Qui his shot by Matias melli two
nothing all right that that's a cracking goal
coot are having it hands It Off K with a shot
and he scores Adrien K taking the drop pass
from Australian native Jordan Spence to get the
ks on the bo guy that got that assist in to Kee
he's ay Jordan Spence middle kuss scores set
up from the corner lawon kuss it St in G that
was a good goal another good goal three to one
coyotes dancing coie scores what a goal by the
youngster 4 to one Arizona might be in the
top five highlights for the coyotes for the
entire season what an absolute belter of a goal
man that was stupid that was genuinely stupid
when the refere puts their arm out there's
a penalty and so if the LA Kings had have
got the puck then they can keep the puck until
the kyot get possession of it right can't clear
scores Victor arson cruising in front a six
goal second period oh have that have have it
Go boys go boys OD man Rush more to the with
a shot he scores Trevor Moore was looking to
pass decided to shoot it's a 4-3 Arizona lead 43
we we are sitting here watching the first period
no goals and then the middle period is going
spicy as they came to give the fans what they
want La has pulled their goalie so they can have
extra attackers and this is what they do to try
and get that one goal they need to tie it up so
they got six six attacking that's a bold maneuver
come on K for Hayden empty net look and he'll
score 53 Arizona is the horn end game one here
in Melbourne 53 Arizona this is going to be an
absolute eye opener to the rest of Australia and
the rest of the world about how much Australians
love hockey 13,097 Australians came to watch LA
Kings Arizona Co is play a preseason game what
a TW man thank you thank you thank you pleasure
I never thought I'd ever see my LA Kings play
in Melbourne so grateful I got to it what did
you think is hockey the best last spy you've
ever seen it it's electric it's fastpac it's
out of control fights goals thanks for coming
what a time what a Time absolute blessing you
gain a new fan today NHL right I can't take the
smile off my face Australia's Got This NHL for
life